[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visual politik zuschauer vor
kurzem haben wir euch in einem anderen
video mit der problematik des aus den
fugen geraten verhältnis ist zwischen
saudi arabien und den usa vertraut
gemacht denn um die hintergründe und
mechanismen der preisbildung an den
globalen energiemärkten zu verstehen ist
es notwendig weit über den europäischen
und vor allem den russischen tellerrand
zu blicken
russland spielt eine gewisse rolle wenn
es um die preise an der tanke geht aber
eine weitaus geringere als die meisten
glauben die musik spielt nämlich immer
mehr und mehr woanders das königreich
saudi arabien exportiert so viel erdöl
wie kein anderes land der welt 2009 10
waren es rund 350 millionen tonnen das
sind circa 15 prozent des weltweiten
exportvolumens die saudis haben einen so
gewaltigen vorsprung dass nach ihnen
erst mal lange nichts kommt zum
vergleich der zweitgrößte exporteur
russland verkauft nur 266 millionen
tonnen und der drittgrößte watte irak
mit 197 millionen tonnen gut damit wären
die größenverhältnisse geklärt aber was
genau ist der grund dafür dass saudi
arabien als mächtigster spieler die
ölpreise nach oben trägt dass dies nicht
einen besonderen freundschaftsdienst
anklagepunkten darstellt wie manche
annehmen handel schon im letzten video
geklärt wir haben euch aber auch
versprochen die wahren ursachen genauer
zu ergründen was wir in diesem video tun
werden anders also wenn meist unserer
videos wollte jedoch nicht mit einem
blick in die geschichte beginnen sondern
umgekehrt mit einem in die zukunft denn
heute man kaum noch jemand das öl bis in
alle ewigkeit eines so gute
einnahmequelle darstellen wird wie es
heute ist
[Musik]
im jahr 2016 hat die saudische regierung
unter der führung von trends machen mit
salman kurs mbs daher an ehrgeizigen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
transformations- plan auf den weg
gebracht ihre sogenannte vision 2030 ein
programm um endlich und ein für alle mal
unabhängig vom erdöl zu werden gesagt
getan nun fast so ein ehrgeiziger plan
ist schnell mit großem tamtam
angekündigt aber ihn in der praxis auch
umzusetzen gestaltet sich meist
schwierig die pannen liste ist lang die
unfähigkeit des staatlichen ölkonzern
saudi aramco an den internationalen
börsen zu notieren eine reihe
größenwahnsinniger projekte ohne klares
ziel und der zusammenbruch der ölpreise
im jahr 2020 haben die finanzen des
königreichs und die tragfähigkeit seiner
vision 2030 strategie inseln wanken
gebracht allein zwischen 2015 und 2020
stieg die staatsverschuldung der
saudischen regierung von 58 prozent des
bip auf über 30 prozent nominal hat sie
sich in nur fünf jahren also mehr als
versechsfacht
[Musik]
und ja 32 5 prozent staatsverschuldung
mark als nicht besonders viel erscheinen
was schon wenn lebenswert wenig im
vergleich mit europäischen verhältnissen
im falle saudi arabiens könnt ihr dies
jedoch irreführend sein vor allem wenn
man bedenkt dass die devisen- und
goldreserven der regierung selbst augen
fast 40 prozent gesunken sind das ist
ein minus von fast 300 milliarden dollar
[Musik]
außerdem reden wir über ein land dass
abgesehen von der prahlerischen
präsentation von großprojekten immer
noch bedenklich abhängig vom öl ist und
erste wirtschaftliche und politische
probleme hat zum beispiel ist ist ein
sehr junges land knapp 70 prozent der 34
millionen einwohner sind unter 30 zudem
schafft der private sektor nur sehr
wenige arbeitsplätze überwiegende teil
der wirtschaftstätigkeit steht unter
direkter kontrolle der regierung und
hängt vom poel business auch dennoch ist
die arbeitslosigkeit unter der junge
bevölkerung relativ hoch und beträgt
etwa 29 prozent das heißt fast jeder
dritte in dieser altersgruppe liegt dem
staat auf der tasche
[Musik]
einmal in saudi arabien fast jeder
zweite arbeitslose langfristig
arbeitslos bleibt das ist ein großes
problem denn wir sollten uns eines vor
augen halten die kombination aus einem
überschuss an jungen männern
arbeitslosigkeit in eine
mittelalterliche verkorksten religionen
mit hohem radikalisierung spot enzian
ist einer der exklusivsten cocktails der
welt zumindest wenn der regierung einmal
das geld ausgehen sollte um all die
arbeitslosen und unproduktiven gut
versorgt bei laune zu halten was die
abhängigkeit vom öl angeht hören wir
alle täglich in den nachrichten dass die
welt sich mittel- oder langfristig auf
andere energieträger verlegen will nicht
nur aus ökologischen sondern vor allem
auch aus finanziellen und geopolitischen
gründen und das macht sich bereits
bemerkbar denn obwohl der weltweite
ölverbrauch in den letzten jahren in
absoluten zahlen gestiegen ist so hat er
relativ zum globalen bip insgesamt
abgenommen der anteil am kuchen der
weltweiten wertschöpfung den die
ölfördernden länder abbekommen stumpft
also stetig sie werden langsam aber
sicher vom rest der durch das geld
regierten welt abgehängt das wissen
natürlich auch die saudis weswegen das
unbehagen in riad nicht zu unterschätzen
ist denn zurzeit machen die gewinne aus
dem ölgeschäft mit rund 87 prozent einen
gewaltigen teil der syrischen
staatseinnahmen aus und etwa 42 prozent
des bip der gesamten 35 millionen
menschen starken volkswirtschaft 35
millionen sehr hungrige münder die
irgendwie gefüttert werden müssen aber
moment mal denn eigentlich hat sich das
blatt doch in letzter zeit gewendet
[Musik]
der durch die korona stadt bei uns
entstanden mangel an investitionen in öl
sektor und der krieg in der ukraine
haben einen aufschwung der rohölpreise
ausgelöst der die saudische wirtschaft
belebt und ihre prognosen für die
kommenden jahre deutlich verbessert
schätzungen gehen beispielsweise davon
aus dass der leistungsbilanzüberschuss
im jahr 2022 mehr als zwölf prozent des
bip betragen wird was bedeutet dass die
verwalter der königlichen stars genossen
durchaus eine atempause einlegen können
bzw geradezu im geld schwimmen aber wenn
wir alle wissen ist der rohstoff markt
extrem zyklisch deswegen klar ist das
ist nicht immer so weiter gehen wird
zumal es schon an sich bedenklich ist
eine so große volkswirtschaft komplett
von den launen des sehr launischen
globalen markt abhängig zu machen keine
angst ich spreche hier immer noch von
saudi arabien die wirtschaftsmodelle von
billig dass junkies die deutschland sind
aber nichts als die umgekehrte seiten
derselben medaille
nachhaltige und robuste wertschöpfung
sieht eben anders aus und während die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft an seinen faden eines
bestimmten preisniveaus beim erdgas
hängt braucht die saudische regierung
nach berechnungen des internationalen
währungsfonds umgekehrt dauerhaft ein
rohölpreis von über 72 04 dollar um
ihren haushalt über wasser zu halten
[Musik]
diese latte überspringen die preise zur
zeit locker wir alle täglich spüren dass
einen freund ist in diesen
schweinezyklus wirtschaftsmodell leben
des anderen leid beim aktuellen
barrelpreis von über 100 us dollar wird
die saudische regierung voraussichtlich
einen haushaltsüberschuss von über 60
milliarden us dollar erzielen während
ihr flaggschiff rainbow ebenfalls
rekordgewinne einfahren wird
wahrscheinlich über 150 milliarden
dollar
über diese ganz besondere firma aramco
zurzeit das wertvollste unternehmen der
welt haben sie übrigens ein eigenes
video gedreht das ich euch verlinken
werde immer wenn saudi arabien ist man
klug genug diese überschüsse nicht
gleich zu verpulvern sondern auch zu
investieren und an dieser stelle kommt
wieder die vision 2030 ins spiel die mit
dem unerwarteten geldsegen nun weiter
beschleunigt werden kann aber um was
handelt es sich bei dieser vision 2030
überhaupt nun ja sie stellt den großen
befreiungsschlag der saudischen
gesellschaft gegen die abhängigkeit vom
öl geschäft dar zumindest ist das der
plan dazu hat man in riad einen breit
aufgestellt ist entwicklungs und
modernisierungsprogramm entwickelt das
sind alle bereiche der staatlichen
ordnungen von verwaltung über wirtschaft
bis hin zu kultur und religion
ausgereift wirtschaftlich soll das land
vor allem stärker liberalisiert werden
es sollen mehr rechtssicherheit und
effektive verwaltung mechanismen
geschaffen und schließlich neue
wirtschaftszweige erschlossen werden
klingt alles ist super dürfte geld aber
dafür braucht es geld in dem falle einer
verkrusteten verzerrten verzogenen und
ineffizienten gesellschaft wie der
saudischen sehr viel geld exorbitante
mengen an geld von dem zwangsläufig sehr
viele den hochriskant aus dem fenster
geworfen werden muss nur damit ein paar
davon ausgehen im oktober 2021 hat die
saudische regierung daher einen
wichtigen teil ihrer vision auf den weg
gebracht eine neue nationale
investitionsstrategie ihr ziel genügend
investitionen anzuziehen und die
wirtschaft des königreichs endlich zu
diversifizieren zu liberalisieren und
damit wachstum stärker zu machen durch
diese neue strategie soll der
privatsektor perspektive stock 65
prozent des bip gebracht werden außerdem
sollen vor allem auch ausländische
investoren angelockt werden damit circa
sechs prozent des bip durch friend
investitionen generiert werden auf diese
weise will man saudi arabien in einem
wichtigen knotenpunkt für internationale
investitionen verwandeln und ein vorbild
dafür haben die saudis bereits sogar
ende region selbst ihr wisst alle von
denen die rede ist den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten vor allem von dubai
die frage ist aber kann man eine großes
land wie saudi arabien wirklich zu einem
neuen dubai machen das doch viel kleiner
ist und entsprechend viel kleinere
probleme hatte wie zum teufel wollen sie
das erreichen und welche rolle könnten
die finanzmärkte bei dieser epochalen
aktion spielen aufgepasst
ein plan ein land komplett zu erneuern
anders als
2020/2021 ein gutes jahr für die
saudische wirtschaft und wir reden nicht
nur über erdöl die nettozuflüsse an
ausländischen direktinvestitionen
stiegen insgesamt um mehr als 250
prozent und jetzt mit der verabschiedung
der national investitionsstrategie will
das königreich der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten bis sich das land kritiker
weise auf der vision 2030 pro monat
selbst nennt noch viel weiter gehen auf
grundlage dieser strategie sollen bis
2030 ausländische investitionen um das
zwanzigfache und inländische immerhin um
das zweieinhalbfache gesteigert werden
damit betrüge die investitionsquote 30
prozent des bip um dieses ziel zu
erreichen muss allein die saudische
wirtschaft in den nächsten acht jahre
mehr als 3,3 billionen dollar
investieren
[Musik]
ihr habt euch nicht verhört billionen
also
3300 milliarden us-dollar ein
pappenstiel licht war da stellt man sich
logischerweise die frage wie wollen die
das überhaupt einstellen welche
veränderungen wird diese neue strategie
mit sich bringen gut hier ein paar
aspekte dazu
erstes saudi arabien will den
kapitalzufluss liberalisieren und so
dass internationale investoren sich an
den meisten sektoren saudische
unternehmen beteiligen können 25 neue
sonderwirtschaftszonen regulatorischen
steuerlichen und finanziellen vorteilen
und ganz wichtig mit die
rechtssicherheit geschaffen drittens
wird die regierung den bau wichtiger
infrastrukturprojekte beschleunigen was
immer ein erster schritt ist um neue
industrien anzulocken
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier von häfen flughäfen
modernen kommunikationsnetzen und so
weiter und so fort viertens wird das
land seine wirtschaftspolitik komplett
umkrempeln und versuchen
freihandelsabkommen mit den großen
volkswirtschaften zu schließen
constance und diese maßnahme ist etwas
umstrittener hat das land eine neue
vergabe regel aufgestellt nur
unternehmen die ihren regionalen
hauptsitz in saudi arabien haben können
öffentliche aufträge von der saudischen
regierung gehalten 6 die privatisierung
staatlicher unternehmen wird ebenfalls
gefördert und das geld das durch den
teilweisen oder vollständigen verkauf
von staatsfirmen eingenommen wird so in
einen public investment an fließen der
weltweit in unternehmen außerhalb der
ölbranche investiert
[Musik]
so soll dieser von etwa 500 milliarden
dollar auf mehr als 1,1 billionen dollar
anwachsen und ja ich habe wieder
billionen gesagt
1100 milliarden dollar die in große
unternehmen wie alfabet apple oder
amazon und viele andere investiert
werden sollen
[Musik]
all diese firmen und ihre aktionäre
dürfen sich also schon mal auf einen
warmen geldregen aus regiert freuen doch
einer ganz bestimmten illusion dürft ihr
euch nicht hingeben diesmal will sich
reas dadurch nicht wie in vergangenheit
nur zu einer art passiven rentiere
weltwirtschaft machen seinen einfluss
als großaktionär will das land auch als
hebel dafür nutzen dass diese
unternehmen mehr in saudi arabien
investieren und als arbeitgeber aktiv
werden geld ist manchmal eben der beste
botschafter
jubel geht eine partnerschaft mit dem öl
giganten aramco ein um zugang zum 10
milliarden dollar cloud-markt den saudi
arabien zu erhalten und wir dürfen
gespannt darauf sein ob die saudis ihre
beteiligungen auch dazu nutzen werden
nach dem vorbild norwegens die welt mit
ideologischen missionars eifer zu
beglücken ein phänomen das wir übrigens
auch schon in einem eigenen video
kritisch beäugt haben ganz abwegig ist
dieser gedanke sicher nicht schließlich
hat saudi arabien er eine recht
unrühmliche vergangenheit was die
finanzierung radikaler moscheen im
ausland betrifft allerdings wird dies
vor allem davon abhängen in welchem maße
das königshaus den wahhabitischen und
salafistischen klerus noch benötigen
wird um das volk bei laune zu halten die
vision 2030 muss diesen ja geradezu wie
eine kampfansage vorkommen will die
regierung doch mit ihren plänen zur
weltlichen qualifizierung oder
emanzipation das volk geradezu auf
entzug setzen vom durch die
geistlichkeit jahrzehntelang
verabreichenden theologischen opium mal
sehen ob den mächtigen glaubens für eine
derartige entmachtung durch die ente
nebelung der gehirne ihrer schäfchen
einfach so hinnehmen werden aber zurück
zur wirtschaft auch wenn ihr seht in
saudi arabien hängt alles mit allem
zusammen denn um ihr bisher eher
dahinter man das volk endlich in
dynamische unternehmer naturen zu
verwandeln will die regierung als achten
und letzten punkt große summen an
partizipative finanzierung bereitstellen
und zwar um die gründung neuer start ups
die etablierung einer mittelständischen
wirtschaft und den start neuer
innovativer investitionsprojekte zu
unterstützen vor allem natürlich in
zukunftsbereichen wie digitaltechnik
saubere energie finanzen und gesundheit
aber nicht nur dort kurzum kronprinz mb
s hat den tonkünstlern die riesigen
dollar reserven zu nutzen und alle
schwächen des landes mit reichlich
elegant kapital zu kompensieren
bei der nationalen investitionsstrategie
geht es darum investoren zu fördern
investitionsmöglichkeiten zu bieten
finanzierungslösungen bereitzustellen um
die letzte das fähigkeit zu verbessern
sie schafft auch klarheit bezüglich der
partnerschafts bestehen öffentlichen und
den privaten sektor denn es ist jetzt
unsere aufgabe den privaten sektor die
tür zu öffnen und ihm wachstum und
wohlstand zu ermöglichen kronprinz
mohammed nissan aber vergessen wir nicht
die natürlichen ressourcen neben dem öl
wie saudi arabien auch seine sonstigen
und nicht weniger riesigen
rohstoffvorkommen ausbeuten so wurden
anfang dezember letzten jahres die
ersten verträge zur nutzung des weltweit
größten schiefergas fans außerhalb der
usa geschlossen zudem werden enorme
summen in die exploration neuer
mineralienvorkommen gesteckt nun all
dies bezieht sich auf investitionen die
direkt also ohne den umweg über die
finanzmärkte getätigt werden der punkt
dabei ist auf diesen gebe es noch mal
deutlich mehr zu holen zumal die
finanzmärkte an sich den größten und
effizientesten mechanismus darstellen
leute mit geld mit denen zusammen zu
bringen die ist aktuell brauchen
deswegen sind anleihen und aktien fern
entscheidende instrumente um sich
effektiv finanzieren zu können ein
weiteres wichtiges ziel von riad ist es
also die saudische börse zu einem
wichtigen internationalen finanzzentrum
zu machen
aufbau eines neuen finanzplatzes
habt ihr jemals daran gedacht in den
saudischen aktienmarkt also auf der tara
wohl zu investieren wahrscheinlich nicht
nicht zuletzt weil dies für einen
kleinanleger verhältnismäßig schwierig
ist wenn er nicht per gießkanne über ets
und indexfonds investieren möchte dieser
umstand ist schon recht bemerkenswert
bei einem der größten aktienmärkte der
arabischen welt und einer der zehn
grössten börsen der welt nun genau diese
isolation wollen dies jetzt abbauen zu
diesem zweck ist die regierung
entschlossen weitreichende änderungen
durchzuführen und diese haben
saudiarabien beispielsweise nur fünf
jahren von platz 83 auf platz 3 der
weltbank rangliste zum schutz von
kleinanlegern katapultiert
so hat auch bereits clearstream einer
tochtergesellschaft der deutschen börse
für wertpapierabwicklung und verwahrung
die saudischen kapitalmärkte an ihrem
netzwerk angeschlossen dadurch wird es
für viele investoren einfacher auf den
saudischen markt aktiv zu sein indem sie
etwa mit dortigen anleihen oder its
handeln können darüber hinaus wird die
regierung im rahmen des
privatisierungsplan den börsengang neuer
aktienpakete der großen nationalen
unternehmen beschleunigen wie etwa das
vorhin erwähnten staatlichen ölkonzerns
aramco von den bisher weniger als zwei
prozent am markt gehandelt werden wohl
eher doch immer wieder das wertvollste
unternehmen der welt ist allein das
zeigt welch globales kuriosum der
saudische kapitalmarkt eben ist und
warum die anpassung an internationale
standards noch einiger anstrengungen
auch überwindung kosten wird trotz
dessen hofft die saudi arabische
regierung all diese veränderungen über
die bühne ziehen zu können so dass sich
in den kommenden jahren viele attraktive
investitionsmöglichkeiten im land
ergeben uns in der lage sein wird großen
mengen an internationalen kapital
anzuziehen denn nur so wird sie ihre
ambitionierte vision 2030 auch umsetzen
können fraglich bleibt aber ob saudi
arabien in der lage sein wird die
zurzeit hohen ölpreise wirklich effektiv
für seine vision 2030 zu nutzen und ob
es rea zudem gelingt auch einen
florierenden finanzmarkt zu etablieren
er weitere finanzen auf die arabische
halbinsel spült aber was meint ihr
würdet ihr euer geld den saudi arabien
investieren oder habt ihr dies eventuell
schon getan stellt die vision 2030 100
diese chance für internationale
investoren dar oder er eine hochriskante
wette auf die unmögliche reform einer
krass verzerrten volkswirtschaft wird
saudi arabiens postfossile wirtschaft zu
einer sprudelnden geldquelle oder er
einen unendlichen loch um eine
bevölkerung aus dutzenden millionen und
undifferenziert orientieren wie immer
sind auf eure beiträge und diskussionen
zu diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat was ja gibt es mit einem leid zeit
oder freunden und vergessen sie das abo
mit glöckchen und keines unserer videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine spende von
euch mit dem set dieses projekt
weiterzuführen den paypal link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung in den
video macht gut bis bald
[Musik]